I want to talk about the French American
wine war for a minute oh yes there's
been a lot of tariffs thrown around
threats and things like that this is a
trade war I'm going to be following very
closely Greg now it doesn't really
affect me too much because I drink Trump
wine and tariffs don't really apply but
I know a lot of people that own
vineyards and they can't get any of
their cabs sold in France because you
know they can't compete in the
marketplace but I like how Trump is
sticking up for the blue-collar workers
in Sonoma Valley these people are the
hardest-working people you'll ever see
President Trump was elected not to be
the president or Denise to be the
president of Napa Valley and these Napa
Valley cabs they can't compete in Paris
now because of these tariffs I just
think this is America first at its
finest I say we go after the cheese next
you know what I think there's gonna be a
case of something arriving here very
soon for you trip one burger yes you
know one I'm gonna defend macron and I
think that he was actually kind of
saying what Trump wanted it which is
like we should have a European army we
should defend ourselves right isn't he
kind of agreeing with Trump in a way I
thought Trump came back and said you
know if it wasn't for us yes wouldn't
exist and yeah I think he was saying you
don't need an army where they are but
you should pay your dues to NATO I think
that's what he was saying yeah yeah yeah
but I think macron was kind of saying
well maybe we should just build up a big
European army and I would think Trump
would go yeah that's pretty good too
right well I don't I don't know I mean
I'm I'm just trying to guess at this
point with Trump but but I do think the
Trump was really upset that McCrone took
him on on the nationalism yeah yeah yeah
when he was saying that Nationals is bad
and clearly Trump has said recently that
he's a national list and I think what
McCrone was saying Oh nationalism means
we don't care about the rest we just
care about us and that this is not the
way the world goes and especially if you
think back on the Armistice and what it
meant in terms of nationalism as
fomenting World War 1 that this would be
a recipe for a new phase of disaster not
learning from history and I think I
think there are a lot of people maybe
not the Moroccan King who are making fun
of Trump for not more
down the champs-elysees not going to the
cemetery no American going to Arlington
National Cemetery no American official
is that my American president and no
White House officials celebrate veterans
on Veterans days that's unbelievable
imagine if Obama did that both Obama did
that you would have a place it's
probably true take that point in stride
but I will say at least this president
funds the military Memorial Day Veterans
Day that was always offended by that
this isn't someone who was it was
beloved by the troops so I don't want to
hear the comparisons between Trump and
Obama first of all second of all this
idea that somehow patriotism and
nationalism are mutually excuse
exclusive it actually doesn't make any
sense
I know Emmanuel macron felt like he was
being incredibly profound when he said
patriotism is the exact opposite of
nationalism nationalism is a betrayal of
patriotism that is not true and in fact
globalism which you could argue is the
opposites of nationalism is very
exclusive to patriotism and and those
who are globalist tend to be apologist
for their own countries like President
Obama he was the epitome of globalism
and he went to other countries he went
to the Brandenburg Gate and he
apologized for the United States I think
we live in a globalist economic world I
was gonna say if you love capitalism if
you love global markets I don't
understand how you can then say oh we
don't care about what's going on over
there I think we're just protecting them
I think in here and then you come into
the idea that nationalism translates
especially white nationalism an illusion
is the shining city on the hill that
attracts people from all the world okay
I did the point the point of there's a
nationalism that seeks to invade other
countries that is not the United States
know what he's putting America first
meaning let's get our stuff together
yeah Jed what are your thoughts on on
this whole thing that we're talking
about take your pick
Trump reminds me of my cat's kanji Lee
what used to happen with scungilli is
that somebody would pull his tail and
he'd look around he'd get a little
agitated and then pull it again get a
little more I should finally the third
time you post a levites he bites back he
hisses that's what Trump does this guy
McCrone was digging at him he did that
you you spoke before about the
anti-nationalist speech that was a dig
then grouping the United States in with
China and Russia as people who they
might have to guard themselves against
that's a dig and then somehow when Trump
responds and says something even
remotely a little bit outlandish or a
little nasty everybody blames chomp if
you poke over and over again he's gonna
stand up for the country he's gonna bite
back people should learn that about
Trump I think that Clint by the way of
the Moroccan the King of Morocco was the
best thing I've ever seen in my entire
life as a former teacher okay Betty
students fall asleep in their class
that's the best thing and I count myself
as the one of Menno dying to see the
reaction design Jeb Bush Jeb Bush why
aren't you all waiting to see though if
he had opened his eyes and you had drunk
just staring it much he must have
snorted in his sleep he must have made a
noise that we didn't catch you know I
think we're burying the lede here Greg
I'm not so much worried about France
standing up an army in the continent the
road for two in the last century you
know they 17 Glory on the battlefield
since Napoleon it's actually Germany
they said they want the keys to the car
of the European army that didn't really
go so well the last time that's like
giving the keys to the Sun that's
wrecked your car twice and say here you
go again she sounds a little bellicose
Merkel I think we could see another land
grab but if they get another army over
there in German a lot of what Mac rod is
doing is what previous French leaders do
they come in with high approval ratings
right but they can't get anything done
because of the unions in France so their
approval ratings gold yeah he's at 26%
and so what you do is you choose the
United States to slap around you know
what was the lesson distraction you know
it's delicious Trump in response to your
point says McCrone is simply engaged in
distracting women because of his lower
back I was like oh my god oh my
like political ploy would you these were
at least he's reading the correct page
in the playbook you know it was exactly
what micron is well that's why I'm dick
but how come a we'll see how come an
American and how come a trump supporters
never get this oh no because I don't
think Trump is never trying to distract
you hope he's just doing what he does
know he's new years now subject to what
he's interested in sometimes we're not
interested in it no